[Music]
you got your start in a new york city
new york city sketch group is that right
that's what got you into comedy i did
ucb a lot did you sketch an improv
upright citizens brigade
they have been so uh
they're great
actually a lot of those players uh amy
poehler a lot of those people started
out uh at ucb they did bits on our show
mcgregor all those guys roberts all
those a lot of those guys uh did and we
were in a sketch team uh called hot
sauce which is me adam pally who's been
on the show he's on happy endings and
gilozeri who's a writer over there um
and we we did we did the montreal comedy
festival which is coming up uh recently
it's a sketch group we haven't traveled
out of the country very often we're in a
van and uh gil is like oh i i don't have
a passport i just have my um birth
certificate i hope they don't make a big
deal out of it i'm like it'll be fine
and we're like one minute away from the
border i'm like oh wait a second in the
sketches we do we have fake cocaine and
fake drugs in them and they're all in
the back of the van right now and you're
a fake cocaine and fake uh fake cocaine
and fake guns oh fake guns right right
fake cocaine would be fake drugs yeah
yeah i made a huge mistake yeah uh and
we're about to we're about to pass the
border like when obviously that is
probably gonna come up and we're talking
about it like oh should we should we say
should we say something and like no no
no i'm like no i think we should
probably say something if there's things
that look exactly like cocaine and guns
in the back yeah you need to disclose
that yes and so we get to the border
thing and gila's like oh i just have my
birth certificate and my passport and
i'm like and also we have fake cocaine
and fake drugs
and they go great everybody out of the
car
and they interrogated us one at a time
at the border but at least you got out
of it we did get out of it i'm not in
jail uh i want to make sure i get to uh
we have a clip here from uh the movie
turbo yes which uh this is about snails
this is about snails it's a dreamworks
animated movie about a snail as the
biggest dream in the universe to go fast
into being the indy 500 and he's played
by ryan reynolds and then i'm in that as
well i play a character named skidmark i
play a snail called skidmark guys
um with snoop dogg
you're moving up the ladder all right
let's take let's take a look at this
clip from turbo
now this is how it's done abjactivate
apply liberally detailing wax on wax off
ah fuel down the hatch
foot massage you know it
relaxing vibes own it brother
that they like survived
are you crazy ow yeah i'm crazy what
made you think i was saying i i i i
don't know how ow are you a car no are
you a car no then stop driving like one
now get out there snail up baby
[Music]
you